Speaker 1: The Trump team is raging over poll
numbers that increasingly show Donald Trump
failing in swing states where Ron Desanctis is
actually doing pretty well. There's a Newsweek
article that summarizes it. Donald Trump's
campaign team has dismissed the finding of a
poll that suggests Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
would be the preferred 2024 candidate against Joe
Biden in key swing states. The Newsweek article
writes. A survey from Republican firm Public
Opinion Strategies shows that DeSantis, who isn't
even officially running yet but is expected to
announce soon, would beat Biden in Arizona and
Pennsylvania in a hypothetical 2024 face off by
48 to 42 and 45 to 42. Poll of 500 registered
voters in Arizona and Pennsylvania also showed
Trump would lose to Biden in the key states if
they faced off again in 2024. So the the Trump
war room account is just attacking the poll. They
put out a tweet saying, quote, Public opinion
strategies. POTUS tried desperately for days to
try to pitch this fake poll to other outlets,
but they refused to disclose their to disclose
their ties to other 2024 candidates and would not
release their crosstabs data. Truly a Post poll.
Now, I have to tell you the reality is this is
not a unique result. I've been telling you for a
while that the polling suggests that while Trump
is doing really well in the primary polling,
DeSantis does better against Biden in much of
the general election polling. And if you take a
look at recent polls, you see that, for example,
in a morning consult poll, Biden leads DeSantis
by one, but Biden leads Trump by three. That's
a general election poll. If you look at that,
then we have the Public Opinion Strategies poll.
There's a whole bunch of different polls You
can look at where Biden does generally better
against Trump, with a few exceptions. So really
the dynamic here isn't unique to the Post poll.
Most polls right now suggest that Republican
voters are supporting the guy who would do worse
against Joe Biden. And that's a problem that the
Republican Party needs to deal with. One or two
more of these and he'll start calling voter fraud
a year and a half out and we'll deal with that
when we come to it. But this is this is a problem
of its own making. DeSantis, by all measures,
would perform better in a national race against
Joe Biden, but can decent his actually get himself
into that position? The Republican primary
polling increasingly suggests that DeSantis
cannot win a national primary against Trump.
And we are going to continue following those
numbers. But the Trump team for now furious.
Anybody would dare to report on that poll.